[Music]  massive crowds gathered around the world  for Saturday's women's March written on  the Statue of Liberty is come come you  tireless pour yearning to breathe free  to breathe free every single day your  job as an American citizen is not just  to fight for your rights it's to fight  for the right of every individual that  is taking a breath whose heart is  pumping and breathing on it's activists  and celebrities like Viola Davis Amy  Schumer Lupita Nyong'o Patricia Arquette  and so many more marched the streets and  took the stage to speak with protesters  it doesn't matter if you got drunk on  your own volition and passed out if you  didn't say no loud enough if you should  have known better because we will always  support you stand behind you beside you  so that you don't have to stand alone  [Music]  you